hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim ok we got some weird
shifting things again I don't know what
the deal is but anyway it's just in that
water over there Liddy's off doing
something with the spiders I don't even
know we're on our way to get the horn if
Jim Americans hear the Gorgon ash ramrod
I'm gonna hey we're off to get a horn
for the gray beard guys so I pick some
stuff see there it is again look at that
so weird since the ripples that are
doing it I don't know why I've got I've
been having some flickering graphical
problems for a while now and I haven't
been able to find the answer but whoa
hey you douche nozzle oh yeah this oh
you are okay
Lydia's got that taken care of now we
are off to some sort of jump some sort
of
what was that oh that's a fighting going
out of here
it's kind of serious let's see what that
hello-o bandits not today who are they
fighting oh they were fighting their
firm answers a giant's toe I don't want
to eat that they're all killing each
other so I don't have to fight him to
file wine silver rig I do need to get
some cooking done oh I found you stick
crab also at first this is where I need
to go for the horn of jar monger doorman
guard I don't know some horn from some
dude who's dead been dead for a long
time there we go all right penny sold to
ingot
not a bad but I need to I'm Laden down
with kids I need to sell my kids I guess
I can hold on for a little bit I still
have that I don't know if I still have
that orcish battle-axe and I know I I
realize now that it might have been I
might have had this deal still one
before still great sort but I don't care
I like the great sword it is Allison and
plus I got my critical benefit to the
great sword Oh what death are you
fighting each other
yeah why are these bandits just in here
and that's what in the first place why
are the bandits in here maybe I should
just let them go at it but then again
that would have been less exciting
okay Lorne I'm here for a horn don't
stand in my way
look more dead people it is crap
staff of zombies going on Lydia you okay
again more people fighting each other to
wrestle now done hurt your home legs
gone hey I wish you could like
decapitate let's go
that and give you rose
people are gonna think I'm weird if I
just keep stripping my enemy's naked
once I kill them I mean isn't that an
actual and that a pretty strange thing
to do I don't know I'll figure it out
then well hello what I was wrong I have
the wrong power shut up [ __ ] another
restless yeah badass no one messes with
the Argonian the beefiest Argonian in
the land
um yeah I'm no I'm not oh that was wrong
I lied I need to go up there
hello what nothing absolutely dick
doodlee okay I guess fine even though
the place I need to go is up I'll go
down ah secret door secret door to
nowhere
hmm he's indeed buddy home for chess
wait was that all that was down here
just some gold that wasn't even in a lot
of gold oh shut up Lydia
God deal with it so I bumped in yeah big
whoop don't get your panties in a bunch
Am I
there's got to be a way to get up stairs
to there and I will find it
eventually ah through there but there's
an iron color der Linde an Indian an
iron helmet now you look okay and ooh
the chest hard to see in here field
battle axe I don't need that why over
encumbered me screw battle axes who who
who uses battle axes anyway no need
got my great sword that's all that
matters Oh who's dead krav houston gruff
depth i'm unleveled up there or is that
just kind of there just I think it's
just a sliver away from a level alright
blue glow big pit
No
the amazing how people lose things in
these worlds and I need to I need to
recover every single lost artifact that
ever was in the entire world no you
don't ya gave me that ancient Nordic
arrows yeah like that hell okay I'm just
wondering why this this one curious dead
I don't know I don't know all I know is
there are things down there to kill oh
well thanks for showing me up with you
ah damn it did not mean to pick that up
okay now I need to get my food damn it
yeah beef up on my menu
booze herbs
Fred ah
who's there no one thinks so chart
skiver hide grim Peaks Oh who's there ah
I knew you were there I'm not
restlessness not a fly watch shut up
[ __ ] long [ __ ] yeah
no one messes with the Argonian oh damn
it I did it again I did it again I keep
doing that I don't have enough bag space
where your crappy weapons and be rusted
out ancient weapons no back space
I've actually wondered are these
dungeons kind of randomized oh hello
nope you're not even getting out today
buddy get him Lydia get him do something
yeah just stand-in there that's great
Lydia shut up Lydia they're already dead
how can you keep talking Lydia I don't
even know why but I know y'all shut up
Lydia
I don't care TRO let's go taking that
gals away move it woman I'm trying to do
some adventure in here ah or don't shut
up shut up
now who else want some you're not
dragger your skille hahaha miss me hey
buddy how's it going long
looks like these guys got boned yeah
[Applause]
ignore that ever happen
Oh Oh with that
something down here is even a point to
me come here ah word give me word
they've become notorious ethereal No
I guess the word was valuable in the
wait nose is different here no dark
can't see anything
aha Cheska chest give me that give me
that give me that give me that don't
give you that keep his AK use that yeah
yeah all right now oh I still don't know
where I'm going I just came in here for
a horn why does this place have to be so
pretty huge who put it down here anyway
who said this valuable artifact at the
Greybeards let's put it in the deepest
darkest dankest dungeon ever even a
thief if someone stole it from them they
wouldn't go into this place and be like
this is a perfect place to hide my
valuables it's just ridiculous all of it
I call BS on
where the heck am I going up here
okay
fires is burning for no reason better
bridge
ah here troll skull I'll take that wall
this garnet not bad worth a pretty penny
okay see something back there
these look like what was that don't let
me get all the way Liddy I saw something
else maybe wasn't Lydia Lydia God you
always get in the way and it's so dark
seriously I've been ah God huh huh ah my
brain Wow Wow my brain oh I can't even
goodness settings to change until
brightness whatever there's nothing up
here
I don't know
fire my god did I come that way or did I
go this way
I don't know ha hello goodbye scattered
into the piece just fall into pieces man
each of these correspond to opening
gates Galloway Lydia you're writing
though you're literally could not be
more in the way than you are now get out
of the way okay so when you stand by
them it light up way and by they don't
light it
what
I think I need to get oh yeah they're
sprinting sprint dang run run boom
yeah perfect screw you Lydia hope you
got trapped hope you got trapped
well watch out Lydia the ground seems to
be on fire ow ow [ __ ] tonight
fire up my ass shut up Lydia no one
cares that you're on fire sorry wonk
don't worry Lydia I got it alright
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next part
bye bye